[Music]
call me
all right so for our jeopardy world guys
we get to see which of our contestants
knows the most about nevada not nevada
nevada tonight here's a look at our
contestants brian loftis beelow
dean ice valdez and chris he's got two
a's in matthew so chris matthews
yeah there's a bunch of eight
there's a couple of them let's go on the
third a yeah
breaks down triple a over here
whoever answers our questions tonight
gets the uh to say they are the coolest
and smartest anchor here at eight news
now you guys ready yes all right we also
want to thank our viewer brett pearson
for sending us this awesome clue oh
thank you
here we go tonight's question is this
southwestern state in the u.s also has a
city named las vegas come on
ah i got this everybody in the studio
here was just like yes
we are taking viewer questions now too
we are too yes and while they're writing
that down if you have a question you'd
like us to use please send it to us
at uh jeffreywarmer warmup newsdown.com
time all right guys ryan we're going to
begin with you your answer is
what is
arizona yes
no there is a las vegas arizona
confirmation no there was not i'm
telling you somebody tells you whether
or not google it yeah well yeah you know
what you're wrong
the answer actually is new mexico yeah
i'm thinking it's new mexico new mexico
yeah so many groups
and i'm not doubting that we double
checked brian you're wrong there's no
las vegas
man brian get some sleep
go home get some sleep tonight
all right
jeopardy
to jeopardy warm up newsnow.com we want
to hear from you guys okay so please
send it to us so we can use it uh as our
next jeopardy question we want to thank
you and don't forget to catch us at
eight news now at 11 online and on your
mobile
still hating it i know i just want to
google it
it's going to be a long night for brian
you're wrong how much heckling is ahead
ryan is going to leave the building
he's going to drive to arizona and
confirm
all right come on over come on over
we're going to arizona
that's on time
[Music]